[Aplausos]
[Música]
buenas a todos hoy os voy a explicar por
qué es fundamental que los jóvenes nos
interesemos en la política antes de nada
me gustaría contaros una pequeña
anécdota veréis estado ya hace un tiempo
quejándome de cosas varias una de ellas
el no tener 18 años decía es que todos
mis amigos ya tienen los 18 no me voy a
poder sacar el carnet de conducir este
verano no voy a poder votar en las
elecciones de abril qué pena qué pena
reflexión más tarde estaría preparado
para votar me parece que es una
reflexión que todos tendríamos que hacer
estamos preparados estamos lo
suficientemente bien instruidos como
para para votar sin que esto acarrea
consecuencias desastrosas y no olvidemos
que hitler llegó al poder ganar unas
elecciones pues no de hecho según el
instituto la juventud el 64 por ciento
los jóvenes europeos no tiene interés
alguno en la política y según la
fundación sm 1 de cada 5 jóvenes se
situó ideológicamente en la extrema
izquierda o en la extrema derecha
y estos son datos realmente preocupantes
verdad porque aunque los jóvenes
representamos únicamente el 1 9% de los
parlamentarios del mundo algún día nos
va a tocar a nosotros las riendas
entonces este desinterés es un lujo que
sencillamente no podemos permitirnos
pero es que ya no sólo desinterés es que
dentro del pequeño grupo de gente que sí
que se interesa la política y que no se
sitúa en algún extremo no hay consenso
dejadme que os ponga en situación cuando
estaba preparando la charla me puse en
contacto con un antiguo alumno el liceo
álvaro dual que lleva pues meses sino
años realizando encuestas en las redes
sociales sobre temas de actualidad la
pena de muerte el modelo de gobierno si
hay república o monarquía en la
exhumación de francos etcétera
me parecen encuestas muy interesantes
porque son un pequeño reflejo de la
realidad sólo que a nivel local en el
círculo de estudiantes del liceo
ya después
y como se puede apreciar la mayores
porcentajes están todos alrededor del
50% como hemos dicho antes no hay
consenso en este grupo
entonces recapitulemos tenemos por un
lado una gran mayoría un gran 64% de
gente que no se interesa la política
dentro del pequeño grupito de gente que
sí que lo hace
tenemos una porción de gente que se
sitúa en un extremo y dentro del pequeño
grupo que nos queda cuando estamos los
otros dos no hay consenso la gente
sencillamente no se pone de acuerdo y me
gusta me gustaría hacer hincapié en esto
me parece que esta recapitulación es tan
importante porque es la única forma de
darnos cuenta un poco de la situación
agónica en la que vivimos cuando estaba
preparando la charla estuve también
indagando un poco sobre las opiniones
que tenía la gente acerca este tema y es
que una de las opiniones que más me
encontré una de las más recurrentes es
que bueno no pasa nada si con los
tiempos que corren que no participe
tanta gente en la vida política no es
para tanto tenemos problemas más
importantes y me parece realmente
preocupante porque a pesar de que espero
que ninguno de los que estamos aquí
presentes
y nos hayamos visto obligados a empuñar
un arma no se inicia que llegamos en un
mundo de luz y color eso lo sabemos
todos el mundo está en guerra lo vemos
todos los días en las noticias la crisis
humanitaria en venezuela el presi de los
populismos en europa la guerra en
oriente medio todo si nuestros abuelos
vivieron dos guerras mundiales dos que
se dice pronto pero eso no significa que
su mundo fuese menos estable que el
nuestro es más ahora con la
globalización en donde una decisión
tomada en un punto a puede afectar a
escalas inimaginables a un punto b
situado miles de kilómetros no estaría
de más pensar que nuestro mundo es
incluso más incierto todavía además con
todas las ventajas que tenemos con
respecto a las generaciones pasadas como
tener acceso a toda la información del
mundo del mundo desde nuestro bolsillo
casi nada tenemos que asegurarnos de no
cometer los mismos errores que nuestros
antepasados de cerciorarnos que el
pasado no se vuelva a repetir eso hay
una forma hacer eso y es interesándonos
a la política y sé que muchos estáis
pensando si eso está muy bien pero qué
hacemos
bien esta es una pregunta bastante
compleja según los expertos hay dos
pasos a seguir por un lado tenemos que
hacer llegar el mensaje a través de
educación fundamental pero además
tenemos que hacer que este se refleje en
la vida cotidiana bien acerca del primer
paso vamos a tomar el ejemplo de españa
cuando estaba preparando la charla me
puse en contacto con amigos míos de
institutos españoles y me comentaron que
en el sistema español no tienen ningún
tipo de asignatura al estilo de belem sé
que tenemos en el sistema francés en el
que básicamente se enseñen pues las
bases de la ciudadanía los valores
constitucionales todo este tipo de cosas
y tal vez ya es el motivo por el cual
según estudio la fundación bv a los
españoles somos los europeos los nos
permitimos en los europeos que menos se
interesan a política y que peor
percepción tiene de políticos e
instituciones mientras que somos los que
menos nos molestamos en informarnos
bien entonces recapitulemos como hemos
dicho antes los españoles somos los
europeos que menos nos interesamos en la
política pero también somos los que
tenemos peor percepción de la situación
actual cómo solucionamos esto educación
no hay otra
un estudio de harvard demostró que un
grupo de estudiantes que habían sé que
habían cursado un año de una asignatura
sobre el gobierno estadounidense tenían
de 3 a 6 por ciento más de
probabilidades de participar activamente
en la vida política del país
aunque hay que tener cuidado ya que el
implementar estas asignaturas una
asignatura que básicamente contemple
esta preparación política como si por
ejemplo en suiza el país de los
referéndums es algo complicado en una
entrevista con the guardian
la señora pudo profesora de la
universidad de work the word big e
impulsoras de él
efe dv habló precisamente estas
dificultades primero tenemos que
entender lo que es el fpv el fpv es una
asignatura que se intentó instaurar en
los institutos británicos que
básicamente enseñarse los valores
fundamentales británicos a los jóvenes
para aumentar la participación en los
procesos democráticos y a pesar de que a
día de hoy esa asignatura existe está
englobada dentro de la asignatura más
general llamada desarrollo espiritual
moral social y cultural entonces éste
como lo considera el señor apuntó kit
básico de la política se pierden es
temas de espiritualidad moralidad y los
otros temas que componen esta asignatura
por otro lado otros problemas que
resalta es el medio de transmisión del
mensaje para ella en el caso de que se
instaurase en estas asignaturas no se
darían por personal docente cualificado
para enseñar ciencias políticas sino
pues por un profesor de turno
con respecto al segundo paso el que
hemos hablado el hacer que esto se
refleje en la vida cotidiana los
expertos concuerdan en que lo que
tenemos que hacer es hacer que nuestra
educación cívica sea automática
de hecho ha venido a rumana el
prestigioso economista dice precisamente
que lo que tenemos que hacer inevitable
e informar nos propone una serie de
medidas como limitar las cargas fiscales
ocultas
y reducir el secretismo sobre la
eficacia de los servicios públicos para
hacer todo esto más accesible para
compensar un poco nuestra
boca
y pretensión a informarnos para así
poder hacer pues precisamente lo que
hemos dicho que nuestra educación cívica
sea automática
entonces en conclusión a pesar de las
grandes dificultades que nos podemos
encontrar en el camino para instaurar
estas clases de esta clase asignaturas
tenemos que hacer todo lo que esté en
nuestra mano y más para asegurarnos de
despertar este interés político en las
generaciones presentes y en las
venideras porque es la única es nuestra
única esperanza gracias
[Aplausos]